♪♪♪
Tyra: THE SEARCH FOR
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
STARTED WITH 14
STARRY-EYED GIRLS...
All: (screaming)
Tyra: AND THE COMPETITION
PROVED TO BE THE TOUGHEST YET.
MORE UNPREDICTABLE
PHOTO SHOOTS...
Jay: HARD TO BEAT.
WHOA, WHOA!
AMAZING MAKEUP.
Tyra: MORE DRAMA...
Ann: I DON'T FEEL--
Kristi: LET ME
OUT OF THE WAY.
Toccara: OH, MY GOD!
(cries)
Tyra: AND MORE
DIFFICULT CUTS.
BUT THE COMPETITION
ENDS TONIGHT
WHEN ONE GIRL WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL IT BE AMANDA,
WHO CAPTIVATED THE JUDGES
FROM THE BEGINNING WITH HER
HYPNOTIC, ICE-BLUE EYES?
Nolé: BEAUTIFUL EYES.
Tyra: HER EYES
ARE BREATHTAKING.
Jay: SO BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: BUT NOBODY KNEW
THAT HER MOST STRIKING FEATURE
WAS ALSO HER MOST TRAGIC.
Amanda: I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
AND I'M GONNA BE ABOUT 30
WHEN I GO COMPLETELY BLIND.
Tyra: AMANDA NEVER LET
HER DISABILITY HOLD HER BACK,
DELIVERING GORGEOUS PHOTO
AFTER GORGEOUS PHOTO.
BUT A TOP MODEL HAS TO LOOK
THE PART IN PERSON
AS WELL AS ON FILM.
TONIGHT, AMANDA HAS TO PROVE
HER STYLE CAN GO BEYOND QUIRKY.
WILL IT BE EVA?
DURING CASTING IN L.A.,
NOBODY SERVED IT QUITE LIKE
LITTLE MISS EVA THE DIVA.
HOW DO YOU COMPARE YOURSELF
TO THE OTHER GIRLS OUT THERE?
Eva: I DON'T COMPARE MYSELF
TO OTHER GIRLS.
I--I'M EVA.
Tyra: 80% OF THE GIRLS
HAVE SOMETHING NEGATIVE
TO SAY ABOUT YOU.
BUT WHEN SHE FOUND OUT
HER ATTITUDE
WAS CAUSING CONTROVERSY,
HER TOUGH FACADE MELTED AWAY.
BUT YOU ARE
A SENSITIVE PERSON
BECAUSE YOU'RE TEARING UP
RIGHT NOW,
AND THAT IS THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PART OF YOU I'VE SEEN.
EVA'S STRUGGLE HAS BEEN MIXING
HER NATURAL SPUNK
WITH A KIND
OF HIGH-FASHION GRACE
A TOP MODEL NEEDS.
TONIGHT, THE SHORTEST
OF THE BUNCH NEEDS TO DELIVER
A BIG PERFORMANCE TO PROVE
SHE CAN RISE ABOVE THE REST.
WILL IT BE YAYA,
THE IVY LEAGUE GRAD WHOSE ROAD
TO BECOME A TOP MODEL HAD
MORE THAN A FEW BUMPS ON IT?
YAYA, WHAT IS YOUR
BIGGEST INSECURITY?
Yaya: MY SKIN.
I NEVER KNOW
WHEN I'M GONNA WAKE UP
WITH MORE PIMPLES AND BUMPS.
Tyra: I FOUND ONE OF THE BEST
DERMATOLOGISTS IN NEW YORK CITY.
WITH HER SKIN TROUBLE
BEHIND HER,
IT WAS YAYA'S NATURAL BEAUTY
THAT STARTED TO BREAK OUT.
YAYA'S INTELLIGENCE
AND GRACEFUL PHYSIQUE
HAVE MADE HER STAND OUT
IN THE COMPETITION.
BUT SOMETIMES
SHE SEEMS COLD IN PERSON.
WILL YAYA PROVE THAT SHE CAN BE
RELATABLE AND REGAL
AT THE SAME TIME?
FROM L.A. TO NEW YORK,
JAMAICA TO JAPAN,
THESE THREE FINALISTS
HAVE BATTLED IT OUT.
TONIGHT, THE SEASON FINALE.
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
♪♪♪
Eva: IT WAS 14,
AND THEN THERE WERE 3.
OH, MY GOD, THERE'S ONLY
A COUPLE OF ELIMINATIONS LEFT
AND THEN SOMEONE'S GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
FOR REAL, FOR REAL.
IT COULD BE ME.
IT COULD BE AMANDA.
IT COULD BE YAYA.
Yaya: THERE'S A THIRD
OF A CHANCE AT THIS POINT
THAT I COULD BE--
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
LIKE...
Amanda: AFTER THE LAST
ELIMINATION
WHEN ANN HAD TO LEAVE,
SHE ONLY HUGGED ME AND YAYA,
AND THEN WALKED RIGHT BY EVA
ON THE WAY OUT.
Eva: BYE, 'NANA.
FOR HER NOT EVEN TO SAY
GOOD-BYE, THAT WAS JUST--
IT WAS CRUSHING.
Amanda: EVA HAD BEEN TREATING
ANN LIKE POO FOR, LIKE,
A REALLY LONG TIME.
AND EVA'S JUST LIKE ME, ME, ME,
ME, ME, ME, ME, ME,
ME, ME, ME, ME, ME, ME.
Eva: I MEAN, THERE'S ALWAYS
CONSEQUENCES AND REPERCUSSIONS
FOR THE THINGS YOU DO.
Ann: WHEN I MET YOU,
I TOTALLY THOUGHT YOU WERE
A DIFFERENT PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW IF I LIKE
WHAT I SEE NOW.
Eva: AFTER THE WHOLE THING
WENT DOWN WITH ANN,
I UNDERSTAND
THE PART THAT I PLAYED.
BUT I TAKE THIS AS A HUGE
LIFE-LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
BEING OFFENSIVE
AND BEING DEFENSIVE
IS NOT SHOWING STRENGTH.
I'M TRYING, AND I'M TRYING
TO BE THIS BETTER PERSON,
BUT NO ONE'S EVEN SEEING IT.
IT'S SO EASY TO JUST PUT A LABEL
ON SOMEBODY AND SHE'S THAT.
Yaya: IF THERE WERE ANYTHING
THAT AMANDA AND I COULD DO
TO MAKE EVA FEEL MORE INCLUDED
OR COMFORTABLE,
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD.
TYRA MAIL.
"ACTRESSES HAVE RECENTLY
BEEN GRACING THE COVERS
"OF ALL THE TOP MAGAZINES.
"BUT IT'S TIME FOR THEM
TO STEP ASIDE AND MAKE ROOM
"FOR A REAL COVER GIRL.
BE READY TO LEAVE
AT 8:15 IN THE MORNING."
Yaya: I'M READY.
Amanda: OKAY, WE READY.
Yaya: THE NUMBER THREE--
IT'S ALWAYS HARD
WITH THREE PEOPLE.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE EXUDING
ANY EXTRA ENERGY
TO MAKE EVA FEEL INCLUDED.
ALL MY ENERGY RIGHT NOW
REALLY NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED
ON WHY I'M HERE.
Eva: AT THE LAST JUDGING,
TYRA SAYS, "THERE ARE FOUR
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME BUT"...
Tyra: THE JUDGES CAN FIND
NOT ONE OF YOU
THAT THEY THINK COULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Eva: I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING,
BECAUSE IT JUST DOESN'T
GIVE US ANY SENSE OF IDENTITY
OR WHERE WE STAND
IN THIS COMPETITION.
Amanda: NONE OF US
ARE STRONG IN EVERY ASPECT.
RATHER THAN JUST LOOK LIKE
A MODEL IN MY PICTURES,
I NEED TO BE STRIKING
IN PERSON.
Yaya: HEY.
Eva: GOOD MORNING.
Jay: AND THEN
THERE WERE THREE.
WELL, TODAY
REALLY IS THE DAY.
IT'S THE COVER GIRL PHOTO SHOOT
FOR WETSLICKS CRYSTALS.
THIS IS A BRAND-NEW
MOISTURIZING LIP GLOSS
THAT COMES OUT THIS CHRISTMAS.
SO THE WINNER
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS GONNA HAVE THE AD
THAT WE SHOOT TODAY
IN A NATIONAL MAGAZINE
AND WILL KICK OFF
HER COVER GIRL CONTRACT.
Yaya: IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
SHOOT, BECAUSE IT'S ONE
OF OUR VERY LAST CHANCES
TO SHOW UP THE OTHER TWO.
Jay: WE'VE GOT THIS WATER POOL
HERE WITH THESE ZEN ROCKS.
THIS IS A VERY
SPECIFIC LAYOUT.
THE LIP IS THE HERO TODAY.
Amanda: I'M GONNA DO MY BEST
NO MATTER WHAT, YOU KNOW.
HOPEFULLY MY BEST
WILL BE GOOD ENOUGH.
Jay: THIS IS THE LIP GLOSS
WITH LASTING CRYSTAL SHINE.
IT'S NOT STICKY,
AND IT ACTS MORE LIKE A BALM
ON YOUR LIPS.
Amanda: HMM.
Man: IT'S GOT THE CRYSTAL--
THE CRYSTAL FINISH IN IT.
Amanda: WHEN YOU'RE A LITTLE
GIRL THINKING ABOUT, LIKE,
WANTING TO MODEL, YOU SAY,
"OH, I WANT TO DO THAT SOMEDAY."
BUT TO BE ON THE PRECIPICE
OF DOING IT IS JUST...
IT'S INSANE.
Ryu: I'M RYU.
Amanda: LYU?
Ryu: RYU.
Amanda: AMANDA.
Jay: R-Y-U
IS HOW IT'S SPELLED.
Amanda: OH, RYU.
Ryu: RYU.
Jay: THEY WANT YOU ON
THE FRONT-MOST PART OF THE ROCK,
LIKE CLOSEST TO THE WATER EDGE
AS POSSIBLE.
Amanda: OKAY.
Jay: NOW, AMANDA, SMILE.
BUT IT'S THAT ENERGY,
THAT BRIGHTNESS,
THAT APPROACHABLE ENERGY--
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
EVEN THAT SMILE YOU'RE GIVING ME
RIGHT NOW WITH THOSE EYES.
Ryu: OKAY, LET'S SHOOT.
Amanda: I WAS REALLY TRYING
TO UTILIZE MY INNER JOY,
YOU KNOW, MY REALLY STRONG
PERSONALITY AND MY APPRECIATION
FOR BUNNY RABBITS AND FRANCE.
Jim: SHE'S GOT
CAMERA-READY SMILE.
Jay: OH, MY GOSH,
SHE'S A COVER GIRL.
Amanda: I WAS SERVIN' UP
A PIPIN' HOT PLATE OF SMILE.
Jay: AMANDA,
OUT OF 40 FRAMES,
YOU'VE GIVEN ME, LIKE,
36 PERFECT ONES.
AMANDA JUST GETS IT.
SHE FEELS IT
INSIDE OF HERSELF.
AND SHE JUST EXUDES THE LOOK
THAT YOU ASK HER FOR.
Jim: GREAT, THAT'S IT.
Jay: THAT'S IT, RYU.
Amanda: WHOO!
Eva: I'M SO EXCITED
TO JUST MAKE IT THIS FAR.
I AM ABOUT TO BE A STAR.
Jay: BE CAREFUL.
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TRY
AND BRING YOUR OTHER ARM
AND YOUR FACE CLOSER
TO THE EDGE OF THE WATER.
EXACTLY.
THAT'S PRETTY.
Eva: KNOWING THAT
IT'S ONLY THREE OF US,
I HAVE NO ROOM FOR MESS-UPS.
I CAN'T TWITCH WRONG,
LOOK WRONG.
NOTHING CAN BE MESSED UP
RIGHT NOW.
Jay: PRETTY.
REMEMBER, I WANT TO KEEP THIS
FRIENDLY AND HAPPY.
AND IT'S ABOUT AN INNER SMILE.
CHIN UP A BIT.
Amanda: I CAUGHT
A LITTLE GLIMPSE OF EVA
HAVING A REALLY PRETTY FACE,
BUT I DIDN'T FEEL THE--
THE ENERGY COMING OUT.
Jay: YES, I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
WHEN I THINK OF WHEN I MET EVA
AT THE CASTING,
THERE WAS THIS TOUGH GIRL
WHO CAME OUT TO SERVE
AND BE STRONG.
AND I THINK, SLOWLY,
THROUGH THIS COMPETITION,
SHE'S LET THAT WALL COME DOWN.
Ryu: YEAH?
Jay: THAT'S IT, DONE.
Man: OKAY, MY DARLING,
FINAL WETSLICK OF THE DAY.
Yaya: EVERY TIME
I GET MY HAIR AND MAKEUP DONE,
THEY TALK ABOUT THIS ELEGANT
THING, THIS REGAL THING.
SO I WAS TRYING TO PULL
FROM ALL THESE DIFFERENT PLACES
LIKE, HOW CAN I BE THAT--
TEE-HEE, HA HA--
KIND OF PERSON?
Jay: LOWER IS A LITTLE
BETTER, YAYA--IF YOU WANT
TO POSITION YOURSELF--
BECAUSE THEN I GET MORE WATER.
Yaya: I WAS FINDING SOME
MENTAL THING TO CONNECT WITH.
YOU KNOW, I'M RECITING POETRY,
OR I'M SEEING LITTLE WAYS
IN WHICH MY EDUCATION'S
KEEPING ME POSITIVE
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE.
Jay: KEEP YOUR ENERGY UP,
YAYA.
REMEMBER, THINK
APPROACHABLE AND FRIENDLY.
Jim: NICE.
Jay: PRETTY.
OH, PRETTY.
IN YAYA'S CASE,
MATHU DID A BEAUTIFUL JOB
ON HER MAKEUP TODAY.
SHE LOOKS FRESH,
NATURAL, AND BEAUTIFUL
WITHOUT EVEN RETOUCHING.
Yaya: (trills) YEAH!
Jay: LAST FRAME, THAT WAS IT.
YOU DID SO GREAT.
BEFORE TODAY, I DIDN'T THINK
ANY OF THE THREE GIRLS LEFT
HAD IT IN THEM.
BUT TODAY, THE GIRLS JUST
ALL STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE.
I THINK IT'S THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE REALIZING
THAT THEY ARE SHOOTING
A REAL AD
IF THEY WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Eva: SO AFTER
THE PHOTO SHOOT,
OUR CHALLENGE IS TO DO A GO-SEE
FOR NORIKO FUKUSHIMA.
Jay: YO.
Eva: HI.
Yaya: HELLO.
Jay: SINCE YOU'VE BEEN HERE
IN TOKYO, YOU'VE LEARNED
ALL ABOUT TRADITIONAL FASHION
AND STREET-STYLE FASHION.
SO J AND I ARE HERE WITH NORIKO
TO TEACH YOU ABOUT
CURRENT
READY-TO-WEAR FASHION.
Amanda: NORIKO IS A MAJOR
FASHION DESIGNER IN TOKYO.
J.: AND NORIKO HAS BEEN
A FIXTURE ON THE FASHION SCENE
FOR THE PAST 20 YEARS.
Jay: SO SHE KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S DOING.
OKAY?
Eva: I'M EXCITED
TO PUT SOME CLOTHES ON AND JUST
SEE SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
Eva: I'M 5'7",
BUT I DON'T HAVE TO BE TALL
TO BE GREAT,
TO KNOW THAT JUST ALL THE NORMS
CAN BE KNOCKED DOWN.
Noriko: (speaking Japanese)
Yaya: THE SKIRT
WAS KIND OF SEE-THROUGH.
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL, BUT IF THAT IDEA
HAD BEEN DONE IN THE STATES,
IT COULD'VE LOOKED VERY HOOCHIE.
J.: THIS IS HER VERSION
OF A WEDDING DRESS,
A VERY MODERN WEDDING DRESS.
Amanda: IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S A SHOW-STOPPER.
IT'S GORGEOUS.
IT WASN'T MY CUP OF TEA.
I FELT KIND OF
OUT OF PLACE IN IT.
Jay: SO NOW YOU'VE BEEN
EVERYWHERE, FROM THE STREETS
TO TRADITIONAL TO HIGH FASHION.
Eva: TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY TWO OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Amanda: WHAT?!
TOP THREE WHO, WHAT?
IT HASN'T SUNK IN YET
THAT I AM FINAL THREE,
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Eva: THIS IS CRAZY.
I CANNOT BELIEVE
THAT I AM STILL HERE.
THAT I AM SO FAR IN THIS
COMPETITION IS SO UNREAL TO ME.
Yaya: I'M DEFINITELY
COMING TO PANEL WITH ANXIETY.
IT'S LIKE ALWAYS SO INTENSE.
AND IT'S JUST GONNA GET
EVEN MORE INTENSE.
Tyra: WELCOME
TO THE JUDGING ROOM.
TONIGHT IS A VERY SPECIAL
ELIMINATION.
ONLY TWO OF YOU
WILL BE LEFT STANDING.
AND THE TWO OF YOU WILL BE
COMPETING IN A FASHION SHOW
FOR THE DESIGNER
NORIKO FUKUSHIMA.
THE PERFORMANCE
IN THAT FASHION SHOW
WILL HELP DETERMINE
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
OF COURSE, YOU ALL KNOW
WHAT OUR AMAZING PRIZES ARE,
BUT LET ME
REFRESH YOUR MEMORIES--
A CONTRACT WITH THE TOP
INTERNATIONAL MODELING AGENCY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
WE HAVE OUR JUDGES,
WHICH YOU HAVE ALL COME
TO KNOW, LOVE, HATE.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS EVER IN EXISTENCE.
WE HAVE NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLé MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND, OF COURSE,
NORIKO FUKUSHIMA.
Noriko: KONNICHIWA.
All: KONNICHIWA.
Tyra: AND MAO,
WHO WILL TRANSLATE FOR HER.
YOU ALL SHOT A COVER GIRL AD.
THE WINNER OF AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL'S PHOTO
WILL ACTUALLY BE A REAL AD
IN MAGAZINES,
WHICH WILL BE THE START
OF HER COVER GIRL CONTRACT.
SO, AMANDA.
Janice: JAPANDA.
Tyra: HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: OH.
Tyra: IT'S CUTE.
Nigel: IT IS CUTE.
Nolé: THAT'S AMAZING.
Janice: IT'S LOVELY.
IT'S SCRUMPTIOUS.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
Nigel: YOU REALLY HAVE
CONNECTED WITH THE CAMERA,
CONNECTED WITH THE AUDIENCE.
MADE THEM WANT TO WEAR
COVER GIRL.
Amanda: I'M GONNA CRY.
Janice: CRY.
CRYING IS GOOD.
Noriko: (speaking Japanese)
Mao: YOUR HAIR
AND YOUR SKIN TONE AND YOUR EYES
ARE SOMETHING JAPANESE PEOPLE
WOULD ADMIRE A LOT.
Tyra: AMANDA, WHAT DESIGNER
DO YOU THINK WOULD LET YOU
WALK ON THE RUNWAY
WITH YOUR GLASSES?
Amanda: IT DEPENDS.
Nigel: YOUR GREATEST ASSET
IS YOUR EYES.
Tyra: IT'S JUST NOT REALISTIC
FOR A GO-SEE
AND FOR A REAL FASHION SHOW.
ALL RIGHTY, AMANDA, THANKS.
UP NEXT IS YAYA.
Nolé: WOW, YOU GIRLS
ARE DOING A GREAT JOB.
Yaya: OH, MY GOD.
THAT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ME.
Nigel: YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT DOES LOOK LIKE YOU.
IT'S WHAT I'VE SEEN OUT OF YOU
RECENTLY, AND IT'S LOVELY
TO SEE IT CAUGHT ON FILM.
Tyra: I THINK
YOUR BONE STRUCTURE LOOKS
REALLY, REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
AND YOU DO LOOK
REALLY SWEET.
Nolé: YOU LOOK APPROACHABLE,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO SEE.
Yaya: I WAS TRYING
NOT TO CONCENTRATE TOO MUCH,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU KNOW,
THINKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
MY LITTLE BROTHER
MAKES ME LAUGH.
Nigel: YOU WEREN'T THINKING
ABOUT THAT CONTRACT?
ENOUGH TO PUT A SMILE
ON MOST PEOPLE'S FACES.
Yaya: THAT, TOO.
Tyra: THANKS, YAYA.
NEXT IS EVA.
Nigel: GOODNESS ME, YOU'RE
MAKING OUR JOBS DIFFICULT.
Janice: CAN WE HAVE
THREE WINNERS TONIGHT, TYRA?
Tyra: I WOULD LOVE TO.
Eva: I WAS THE ONE
THINKING ABOUT THE CONTRACT
WHILE SHOOTING, AND THAT'S
WHAT KEPT ME MOTIVATED.
KEPT ME SMILIN',
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT I WANNA SEE
WHEN I OPEN UP A MAGAZINE.
Tyra: I THINK YOUR SKIN IS,
LIKE, AMAZING ON THIS PICTURE.
IT'S LIKE SO EVEN
AND SO SMOOTH.
Janice: SKIN LIKE HONEY.
Noriko: (speaking Japanese)
Mao: IT REALLY LOOKS LIKE
THE SMILE COMES FROM WITHIN,
AND LOOKING AT THIS PICTURE
MAKES ME FEEL HAPPIER.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY, EVA.
THANKS.
WELL, BEFORE I SEND YOU AWAY,
I JUST WANT TO APPLAUD
ALL THREE OF YOU.
'CAUSE Y'ALL
ARE THE THREE SHORTEST GIRLS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
Eva: I SAID THAT!
I SAID THAT.
Tyra: NOW THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN THE FASHION WORLD
THAT MIGHT BE GAGGING, GOING,
"OH, THIS IS BLASPHEMOUS!"
AND I THINK YOU ALL ARE GIVING
GIRLS HOPE THAT THEY'RE LIKE,
"I AIN'T 5'9",
BUT IT JUST MAY BE OKAY."
LAST WEEK WHEN I SAID
WE DIDN'T THINK THAT YOU GUYS
WERE REALLY READY,
THOSE PICTURES
PROVED US VERY WRONG.
THANKS, GUYS.
Janice: SAYONARA.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE THREE GIRLS
SHOULD GO HOME.
Nolé: OH, GOSH.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Noriko: (speaking Japanese)
Mao: HER SKIN
IS EXTREMELY TRANSLUCENT
AND HER HAIR IS BEAUTIFUL.
Nolé: THE ICE QUEEN
HAS COMPLETELY MELTED AWAY
AND A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN
CAME OUT.
Tyra: THIS PHOTO OF HER
IS ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
Nigel: AMANDA STILL NEEDS
TO WORK IN PERSON
TO LOOK LIKE THIS.
WHEN I'M LOOKING AT HER,
SHE'S OFF ON ONE LEG,
AND SHE SEEMS LIKE HER BODY'S
SLIGHTLY OFF ON AN ANGLE
ALL THE TIME.
Janice: AMANDA,
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH, NAILS IT--
HANDS DOWN, BAR NONE.
Tyra: EVA.
Nigel: SHE
IS THIS LITTLE TOMBOY.
SHE'S NOT THE GIRL THAT YOU
NECESSARILY THINK IS GONNA
PULL OUT A PICTURE
LIKE THIS.
THIS IS A GREAT, BEAUTIFUL,
WARM PICTURE.
Nolé: THIS IS THE GIRL
THAT EVERY GIRL IN AMERICA
WANTS TO KNOW
AND WANTS TO BE.
SHE'S UNIVERSAL.
Janice: EVA HAS COME
LIGHT-YEARS.
SHE'S LEAPT, AND SHE'S LEARNED,
BUT I STILL WANT TO SEE CHIC.
AND I DON'T GET THE ESSENCE
OF CHIC ABOUT HER.
Tyra: YAYA.
Nolé: SHE'S
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
YAYA HAS INCREDIBLE
BONE STRUCTURE.
Nigel: YAYA IS REALLY
ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
I THINK WE'VE HAD.
Nolé: I AGREE.
Nigel: SHE'S STUNNING.
AND WHEN SHE STANDS
IN FRONT OF YOU, SHE'S ELEGANT.
SHE'S REGAL.
BUT THOSE THINGS ARE ALSO HER
DOWN POINTS SOMETIMES.
SHE DEFINITELY HAS THAT SLIGHT
ARROGANT SORT OF SNOBBISH THING
ABOUT HER.
Janice: THAT'S YOUR OPINION.
Nigel: WELL,
IT IS MY OPINION.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT?
Janice: SO THAT DETERS
THE WAY SHE WALKS,
THE WAY SHE LOOKS,
THAT SHE HAS AN AIR ABOUT HER?
Nigel: PHOTOGRAPHICALLY,
IT'S HARD TO CRITICIZE HER.
SHE'S HAD CONSISTENT
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
AS HAS AMANDA.
AS HAVE ALL THREE GIRLS,
I THINK, BUT, UM--
Janice: THIS PICTURE
CROSSES ALL BORDERS.
I THINK YAYA'S GOT
THE COVER GIRL LOOK.
Tyra: THIS IS, LIKE,
THE HARDEST JUDGING I'VE EVER--
Janice: IT'S SO HARD.
Nigel: ALL THESE GIRLS CAN
DO PRETTY WELL PHOTOGRAPHICALLY.
SO IT'S A DIFFICULT ONE
FOR ME TO DECIDE ON.
Tyra: I'M SHAKING, YOU GUYS.
Tyra: I HAVE THREE LOVELY
LADIES STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TWO PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
THESE TWO PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE TWO FINALISTS.
THESE TWO FINALISTS WILL COMPETE
IN A NORIKO FUKUSHIMA
FASHION SHOW
AND WILL WALK
AND SASHAY TO THE DEATH
TO SEE WHO CAN BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
Tyra: YAYA.
Yaya: (sighs)
Tyra: YAYA, YOU WALKED
IN HERE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL
WITH GREAT STATURE
BUT A LITTLE BIT
TOO MUCH STATURE,
BECAUSE YOU WERE THE DANCER.
BUT THESE JUDGES HONED THAT IN.
NOW YOU'RE A MODEL.
YAYA, YOU ARE A FINALIST.
THERE IS A 50/50 CHANCE
THAT YOU WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Yaya: (sighs)
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
Yaya: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL EVA AND AMANDA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS ONE PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR JAPANESE HOMESTAY,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
YOU TWO ARE A VERY INTERESTING
LITTLE DUO HERE.
YOU GUYS BOTH HAVE
WHAT THE OTHER NEEDS.
AMANDA, YOU HAVE EDGY, FIERCE,
HIGH-FASHION AMAZINGNESS.
EVA, YOU HAVE APPROACHABLE,
RELATABLE,
BUT TO BE A TOP MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE BOTH.
SO YOU GUYS
ARE INCOMPLETE PACKAGES.
THERE IS ONE OF YOU
THAT THE JUDGES THINK
IN THIS SHORT TIME
MIGHT BE ABLE
TO PULL IT TOGETHER.
Tyra: EVA.
Eva: OH!
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE A FINALIST.
Amanda: THANKS AGAIN.
Tyra: YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOIN' HOME TONIGHT, DIDN'T YOU?
Janice: (sighs)
Janice: LOVE YOU.
Amanda: (speaking Japanese)
I'M PRETTY SURPRISED.
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA BE
FINAL TWO.
I WANTED TO WIN SO I COULD GET
THAT $100,000 CONTRACT
AND BUY A HOUSE.
AT LEAST I GOT TO DO THIS.
I WANT TO INSPIRE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE DISABILITIES
OR, YOU KNOW, SHORTCOMINGS
TO JUST, LIKE, WORK THROUGH IT
AND TO FIND JOY IN EVERYTHING.
Eva: WELL, AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL IS, LIKE, ONE OF US.
EITHER THE TOMBOY
OR THE AFROCENTRIC ONE
IS GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YAYA AND I ARE FINAL TWO NOW.
NEVER IN A MILLION YEARS
DID WE THINK THAT WE WOULD BE
THE LAST TWO.
DID YOU NOTICE THAT WE ARE
EACH OTHERS COMPETITION?
IT JUST BLOWS ME THAT IT'S STILL
TWO BLACK GIRLS HERE.
WE ARE EACH OTHERS COMPETITION.
Yaya: (laughs)
EVA AND I, UP UNTIL THIS POINT,
HAVEN'T FELT COMFORTABLE
AROUND EACH OTHER.
WE JUST DIDN'T FIND
THAT CONNECTION.
AND SO NOW IT'S JUST HER AND ME.
WE JUST LET OUR GUARDS DOWN.
Eva: WHAT MADE ME DIFFERENT
THAN THE OTHER GIRL
SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO ME
THAT IS EQUALLY AS BEAUTIFUL?
AND TALLER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'?
STRAIGHTER TEETH
AND GLOWIER SKIN.
Yaya: HELLO.
CLEARER SKIN.
NESTLE CRUNCH BAR
AND, "YEAH, SHE'S CUTE, BUT..."
Eva: WHAT I'M LEARNING
ABOUT YAYA IS THAT SHE
HAS HER DEFENSES UP,
BUT THAT THERE IS A SWEET PERSON
UNDERNEATH ALL OF THAT.
IN THIS WHOLE TIME,
I WAS UNABLE TO SEE THAT.
Yaya: THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THAT WALKED INTO L.A. LIKE...
(snaps fingers)
I GOT IT.
NOBODY WALKED IN LIKE THAT.
IT JUST MAKES ME HAPPY
THAT THE PERSON THAT'S GONNA WIN
IS GOING TO BE A BLACK WOMAN
WHO HAS FLAWS,
WHOSE HEAD IS ON HER SHOULDERS
AND WHO IS A POSITIVE PERSON.
Eva: THIS IS SO RETARDED.
Yaya: IT'S SO REFRESHING
TO BE ABLE TO FINALLY SEE
A LITTLE BIT OF HER
FOR WHO SHE IS, AND I'M LIKE,
"WHY COULDN'T IT HAVE BEEN
THIS WAY THE WHOLE TIME?"
Eva: I WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING, AND IT'S TIME
FOR OUR ONE-ON-ONE WITH TYRA
BEFORE OUR FINAL CHALLENGE.
Tyra: SO HAVE A SEAT,
MISS EVA.
SO HOW ARE YOU FEELING
RIGHT NOW?
Eva: NEVER IN A MILLION YEARS
COULD I HAVE IMAGINED--
I MEAN, MODELING,
BECOMING A SUPERMODEL IS JUST--
IT'S JUST A DREAM,
NOTHING THAT I EVER THOUGHT
WAS OBTAINABLE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S TWO PEOPLE LEFT,
AND THEY'RE BLACK.
GET THAT.
LIKE, WHAT?
Tyra: IT'S NOT ABOUT US
THINKING, "OH, A BLACK GIRL
NEEDS TO WIN THIS YEAR."
IT'S JUST THE TWO BEST
WERE BLACK GIRLS.
I KNOW YOU TOLD ME
THAT YOU WERE KIND OF ALIENATED,
YOU KNOW, FROM THE OTHER GIRLS.
HOW DO YOU THINK IT'S GONNA BE
NOW THAT THERE'S TWO?
Eva: IT'S WEIRD,
BECAUSE YAYA AND I HAVE NEVER
TAKEN IT UPON OURSELVES
TO GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
BUT WE WENT THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER,
AND WE BOTH KNOW.
AND TO BE ENEMIES HERE AND NOW
IS SO POINTLESS.
Tyra: WAS THERE ANYTHING
YOU WANTED TO ASK ME?
Eva: WHAT DO YOU SEE IN ME
THAT SHOWS YOU
THAT I HAVE SO MUCH POTENTIAL?
Tyra: A GIRL
THAT IS VERY TROUBLED
BUT IS DEALING WITH THAT
AND IS TRYING TO BE BETTER.
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT PERFECTION,
BUT IT'S ABOUT STRIVING
TO IMPROVE OURSELVES.
Eva: OH, I'M ABOUT TO CRY.
UM, IT IS SO AMAZING,
BECAUSE IF I LOOK AT MY PAST,
WHAT I'VE GONE THROUGH,
TO TRY TO PREDICT MY FUTURE
AND SAY, "IN FIVE YEARS
WHERE WOULD I BE?"
ALL I WANTED
WAS SOMEWHERE TO SLEEP
OR SOMEONE TO HOLD ME
OR SOMEONE TO LOVE ME.
AND I HAVE ADMIRED
SO MANY PEOPLE IN MY TIME.
I COULD POSSIBLY BE SOMEONE
THAT EVERYBODY ADMIRES,
AND WHAT?!
YOU KNOW, THERE'S NEVER
A TESTIMONY WITHOUT A TEST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Tyra: HELLO.
Yaya: HI, TYRA.
HOW ARE YOU?
Tyra: I'M HYPERVENTILATING.
Yaya: I AM, MY GOSH.
I'M JUST COMING BACK DOWN
FROM, LIKE, TO REALITY.
I WASN'T EXPECTING YOU
TO CALL ME FIRST
OR AT ALL, I DON'T KNOW,
IT'S JUST--
Tyra: WHY WERE YOU
QUESTIONING YOUR BELONGING HERE?
Yaya: BECAUSE
I'M USUALLY VERY--
AND I DON'T LIKE THE WORD...
(whispers) AFROCENTRIC,
BUT IT'S JUST VERY NATURAL
FOR ME TO WANT TO EXPRESS THAT,
YOU KNOW, AND TO WANT
TO BE PROUD.
I NEVER WANTED TO, YOU KNOW,
FILL THIS MOLD THAT I FELT
THAT EVERYONE ELSE WAS FILLING.
Tyra: YOU KNOW,
YEAH, I'LL WEAR A HAIR WEAVE,
BUT I'M STILL A BLACK WOMAN.
AND I'M STILL
REPRESENTING BEAUTY TO PEOPLE
THAT NEVER REALLY THOUGHT
BLACK WOMEN WERE BEAUTIFUL.
THERE'S A WAY TO MAKE PEOPLE
LOOK AT YAYA AND SAY,
"OH, MY GOSH,
YOU HAVE THE KENTE CLOTH
"AND IT'S THIS AND IT'S THAT,
BUT I'M A WHITE FROM ALABAMA,
"AND I STILL LIKE HER.
I'M NOT INTIMIDATED BY HER."
DO YOU UNDERSTAND ABOUT STILL
HOLDING ONTO WHO YOU ARE
BUT BEING ABLE TO RELATE
TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE?
Eva: GET READY, BACKSTAGE.
Yaya: OOH.
Eva: I'M ABOUT TO COME SHOW
YOU SOME BLACK BOOTY.
TODAY'S THE DAY.
WE HAVIN' A FASHION SHOW,
AND I CAN WALK.
SO I SO WANNA WIN THIS,
AND I'M GONNA SHOW IT
IN EVERY STEP OF THE WAY TODAY.
I'M GONNA KILL IT.
Jay: YAYA, EVA, HOW ARE YOU?
Eva: HI.
Jay: THE TWO GIRLS
IN THE HOUSE.
Yaya: I DEFINITELY HAVE
THOSE BUTTERFLIES IN MY STOMACH
GOIN' ON, AND I FEEL
THE SAME WAY I DID
WHEN I WALKED ACROSS THE STAGE
AND GOT MY DIPLOMA.
AND I KNOW I HAVEN'T WON YET,
BUT...
(sighs)
ALMOST.
Both: (scream)
Jay: SO, YEAH, I KNOW, RIGHT?
EXCITING.
SO THIS IS NOT A SHOW
FOR YOU TWO.
IT'S A REAL
FASHION SHOW FOR NORIKO.
Yaya: THIS IS NOT AN EVENT
FOR THE TOP TWO OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THIS IS NOT ABOUT US.
OOH.
Eva: OH, LOOK AT THE STAGE.
LOOK, PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
SITTING IN THE MIDDLE HERE.
Yaya: WE NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT KIND OF RUNWAY.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
BACK AND FORTH, YOU KNOW,
ON THIS VERY LINEAR RUNWAY.
THOSE 45 DEGREE, LIKE, HOW DO
I KNOW TO STEP WITH THIS FOOT
OR THE ONE OVER OR, YOU KNOW,
DO I LOOK HERE AND THEN GO?
Jay: WE'RE GOING FOR A VERY
JAPANESE ZEN-STYLE SHOW.
THEREFORE THE WALK
IS A VERY SOMBER, VERY SLOW.
Eva: WHAT?!
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TAUGHT HERE
SO FAR IS HOW TO BE FIERCE,
JUST GIVE IT AND BRING IT.
I'M DEFINITELY NERVOUS.
Jay: AND YOU JUST FOLLOW
THE PATTERN OF THE RUNWAY.
Yaya: SEEING
THESE OTHER MODELS,
IT WAS REALLY COMFORTING.
I JUST FELT LIKE,
"OH, I CAN DO THIS."
Yaya: THIS IS THE END,
AND THIS IS THE FASHION SHOW.
AND OUR JOB IS TO STEP UP
TO THE PLATE AND ACT
LIKE WE DO THIS ALL THE TIME.
Eva: THIS IS DEFINITELY
EVERYTHING I'VE EVER DREAMT OF,
FROM GETTING MY MAKEUP DONE
TO GETTING MY HAIR DONE.
OH, MY GOD.
IT'S LIKE GRADUATION.
Jay: YAYA.
EVA.
Eva: I'M DEFINITELY NERVOUS,
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT ALL
IS RIDING ON THIS.
AND IT'S LIKE, WHOA,
THIS IS IT.
DON'T MESS UP.
Tyra: ARE YOU READY?
Eva: YES.
Tyra: ARE YOU NERVOUS?
Tyra: I'M NERVOUS, TOO.
YOU GUYS ARE WITH REAL MODELS
TODAY, SO YOU HAVE TO STEP UP.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR A LOT LONGER THAN YOU HAVE.
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY
LOOKIN' AT YOU, LIKE...
SO YOU GOTTA
SERVE IT RIGHT BACK.
Yaya: MY HEART WAS BEATING
FAST, AND I JUST HAD TO,
LIKE, REFOCUS AND RECENTER.
AND THIS IS JUST IT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
Jay: OKAY, THIS IS JAY.
WE ARE GOING TO
START THE SHOW NOW.
Jay: I'M SENDING OUT
THE TAIKO DRUMMERS.
WE ARE GOING TO
START THE SHOW NOW.
(drums play)
Eva: THIS IS
THE FINAL COMPETITION,
THE FINAL CHALLENGE
IN DETERMINING WHO WINS.
Yaya: THE DRUMS
JUST MADE MY HEART BEAT FASTER,
MADE ME SO MUCH MORE NERVOUS.
Both: HA!
Jay: GO!
♪♪♪
Jay: OKAY, YAYA, GO.
Janice: YEAH!
Yaya: WALKING OUT
ONTO THE RUNWAY AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO LOOK AT THE PEOPLE,
BUT JUST FEELING THEM
WATCHING ME IS EXHILARATING.
Eva: I LIKE TO WALK STRONG
AND JUST SERVE IT.
BUT THIS FASHION SHOW
DIDN'T ALLOW ME TO DO THAT.
BACKSTAGE IS CRAZY.
EVERYONE'S GETTING DRESSED.
PEOPLE ARE YELLING
AND SCREAMING.
Jay: I NEED MORE GIRLS!
MORE GIRLS!
Eva: IT'S MADNESS BACKSTAGE.
Yaya: AS SOON AS I GOT
MY CLOTHES ON, IT WAS MY TURN.
Jay: OKAY, I NEED YOU NOW,
RIGHT NOW.
GO.
Janice: YAYA!
FASTER!
Jay: OKAY, I NEED YOU NOW,
RIGHT NOW.
Janice: OH, THAT'S PERFECT.
Eva: I LOOK AT MY RACK
AND IT'S MY LAST OUTFIT.
Jay: THIS IS YOUR
LAST OUTFIT, GIRLS.
Eva: THIS IS MY LAST
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW THEM
THAT I AM WORTHY.
Jay: BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
LET'S GET YOU FIRST.
FIRST, FIRST, FIRST.
OKAY, YOU TWO,
YAYA, NOW.
Janice: LOVE THAT.
Yaya: EVERY TIME
I EXIT THE STAGE,
EVA CROSSES IN FRONT OF ME.
THE RULE IS LET THE PERSON
WHO'S ENTERING GO FIRST.
I WAS WAITING FOR HER
TO GO, GO, GO, GO.
I REALLY HAD TO SLOW DOWN.
Eva: THERE COULD HAVE
DEFINITELY BEEN A HUGE
CRASH COLLISION THERE.
♪♪♪
(cheers and applause)
Yaya: THE SHOW WAS OVER,
AND IT'S OUR LAST CHALLENGE.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT MY PERFORMANCE.
SO MY CHANCES OF WINNING
ARE VERY GOOD.
Eva: I FEEL GREAT.
I FEEL LIKE I WAS ON POINT.
I FEEL LIKE I DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
Jay: YOU GUYS
WALKED AT THE RIGHT PACE.
YOU GUYS WERE DEAD ON.
SO NOW THE TWO OF YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA GO TO JUDGING...
Eva: ALL RIGHT.
Jay: FROM HERE.
Yaya: RIGHT NOW.
Jay: RIGHT NOW.
Yaya: IT'S JUST
FROM THE FASHION SHOW
STRAIGHT TO PANEL.
EVA KIND OF COLLAPSED
INTO MY BOSOM.
SHE'S MY COMPETITOR,
BUT AT THAT MOMENT, I FELT LIKE,
"ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO."
Eva: THIS WHOLE
COMPETITION STUFF IS OVER.
IT'S TIME TO GO TO PANEL,
AND ONE GIRL IS ABOUT TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: BEAUTIFUL.
WELL, YOU GUYS, THIS IS IT.
WE'VE WATCHED BOTH OF YOU
TRANSFORM FROM LITTLE GIRL
FROM NEW YORK,
LITTLE GIRL FROM L.A.,
INTO BEAUTIFUL,
WORLD-CLASS MODELS.
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU CAN BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER TONIGHT
IS GETTIN' SOME AMAZING PRIZES.
Both: MM-HMM.
Tyra: THE FIRST IS A BIG,
FAT CONTRACT WITH THE TOP
INTERNATIONAL MODELING AGENCY
FORD MODELS.
THE WINNER WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON
IN A PHOTO SPREAD
FOR "ELLE" MAGAZINE.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
FOR COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW, OF COURSE, OUR JUDGES--
JANICE DICKINSON, ONE OF
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODELS.
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLé MARIN, PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND THAT'S IT TONIGHT.
AS YOU GUYS CAN SEE,
THERE IS NO GUEST JUDGE.
THAT'S BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU BEST.
WE KNOW YOUR STRENGTHS,
AND WE KNOW YOUR WEAKNESSES.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR EVALUATIONS.
AND THEN AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Eva: (sighs)
Yaya: OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: BOTH OF YOU WALKED IN
A VERY IMPORTANT FASHION SHOW
FOR DESIGNER NORIKO FUKUSHIMA.
NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT YOUR FOOTAGE.
Nigel: YAYA, WHEN YOU WALKED
OUT ONTO THAT RUNWAY,
I WAS BREATHLESS.
YOU LOOKED BEAUTIFUL.
Nolé: YOU WERE SO TECHNICAL.
IT WAS ACTUALLY VERY IMPRESSIVE.
BUT I FELT THAT IT LACKED
A LITTLE BIT OF A PERSONALITY.
Janice: YAYA,
YOU FIT RIGHT IN.
BUT THE LOOK ON YOUR FACE
WAS THAT OF A ZOMBIE.
IT WAS GLACIAL.
I THINK YOU'LL GET IT
THE NEXT TIME
YOU HAVE A FASHION SHOW.
Tyra: MY MAMA MADE A COMMENT.
SHE WAS LIKE,
"LOOK AT HER BOOTY.
OH, SHE'S GOT A GREAT BODY."
Nigel: EVA,
I REALLY LIKED YOUR WALK.
YOU HAD THE ZEN,
STILL THAT LITTLE BIT
OF EVA SORT OF SWAGGER TO IT.
Tyra: ONE THING THAT I
NOTICED THAT YOU DO,
ESPECIALLY ON THE PROFILE,
IS YOU DO THIS.
Janice: A LITTLE EGRET.
Tyra: IT WAS, LIKE,
PROPELLING YOU FORWARD.
YAYA, YOU WERE DOING
TOO MUCH HEEL-TOE.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THAT PRESSURE
MORE ON THE BALLS TO MAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT MORE ELEGANT.
YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR 12 WEEKS.
AND YOU'VE TAKEN
SOME BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
HERE'S YOUR FIRST WEEK HERE.
SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME AGO.
Nigel: I THINK THIS WAS WHEN
I FIRST NOTICED YOU, YAYA.
YOU NAILED THIS LOOK, I THINK,
BETTER THAN ANY OF THE GIRLS.
Janice: EVA, YOU'VE GOT IT
IN THE EYES BUT EVERYTHING ELSE
IS COLLAPSED.
Tyra: EVA,
YOURS IS A LITTLE COMMON.
YOU WEREN'T SUPER COMFORTABLE
MODELING YET.
SO YOU WENT TO THE COMFY,
JUST CHILLIN' OUT POSE.
Janice: THAT'S LIKE A POSE
THAT WE ALL DO
IN THE FIFTH OR SIXTH GRADE.
Tyra: HEY!
Janice: IN THE SCHOOLYARD--HI.
Nolé: THEY BOTH ARE JUST
INCREDIBLE, INCREDIBLE SHOTS.
Nigel: I THINK YOU BOTH
STEPPED IT UP A NOTCH HERE.
Nolé: EVA, THIS IS WHEN
I REALLY STARTED TAKING NOTICE
OF YOU AS A BEAUTY GIRL.
Nigel: YAYA, FOR ME, IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT YOU WERE BEAUTIFUL
STRAIGHT AWAY.
IN THIS PICTURE,
YOU NAILED IT.
Tyra: THIS WAS
YOUR ALTER EGO WEEK.
Janice: EVA, GORGEOUS.
DROP-DEAD KNOCKOUT PILL
BETTY GRABLE, RITA HAYWORTH,
JUST GORGEOUS.
Nolé: THIS
IS WHEN THE COMPETITION
REALLY GOT TOUGH.
EVA, YOU NAILED THIS SHOT
IN BOTH.
YAYA, THE ONE SHOT,
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE CAR,
IS VERY COUTURE,
BUT I DON'T LIKE
THE NATURAL SHOT.
IT DOESN'T SAY ENOUGH.
Tyra: THAT'S CRAZY.
YAYA'S PICTURE CAME UP,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"WHAT'S MY PICTURE
DOIN' UP THERE?"
Nolé: EVA, YOU WERE THE ONE
WHO WAS PETRIFIED OF THE SPIDER.
BUT IN THE PASSION OF YOUR EYES,
I DON'T SEE IT AT ALL.
Nigel: YAYA, FOR ME,
IT'S THE MOST UNBELIEVABLE SHOT
I'VE SEEN OF YOU.
I THINK IT'S THE BEST SHOT
YOU'VE TAKEN SO FAR.
GORGEOUS PICTURE.
Tyra: I DID A LITTLE DEMO
FOR YOU WITH THIS SHOOT.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH YAYA,
BECAUSE YOU WERE TAKING NOTES
IN YOUR HEAD WHEN I WAS POSING.
Nolé: EVA, I MUST SAY
THAT I LIKE YOUR BODY LANGUAGE
IN THIS SHOT.
Nigel: YOU TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
NOT PARTICULARLY TALL,
AND YOU ANGLED YOUR LEG NICELY.
Janice: OH, EVA DIVA,
THIS IS EVA DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE.
GIRL, YOU'RE SLAMMIN'
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
Nigel: YAYA, THERE'S
NO ARROGANCE IN THIS PICTURE.
YOU'RE JUST VERY APPROACHABLE.
Nolé: EVA WAS SO FRIENDLY.
IT'S SO WARM AND INVITING.
Tyra: I KNOW COVER GIRL'S
MOTTO IS LIKE A GOOD GIRL
WITH A WINK.
AND I THINK
BOTH OF YOU HAVE THAT.
AND I THINK BOTH OF YOU WOULD
MAKE A REALLY GREAT COVER GIRL.
Janice: WINNING LOOKS.
Tyra: YEAH.
SO NOW IT IS TIME
TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Nigel: BOTH YAYA AND EVA
ARE STRIKING IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
EVA HAS AN UNUSUAL LOOK
THAT I SEE MORE OF RIGHT NOW.
YAYA HAS A VERY OLD-FASHIONED
LOOK FOR ME.
AND SO IT'S NOT THAT I PREFER
ONE OVER THE OTHER,
I'M SORT OF GOING
BACK AND FORTH.
Tyra: INTERESTING
THAT YAYA DOESN'T HAVE
MODELING EXPERIENCE,
BUT VERY EARLY ON WAS MOVING
KIND OF LIKE A PRO.
Nolé: TODAY, I ALMOST
FELL DOWN WHEN I SAW
HOW INCREDIBLE EVA LOOKED.
SHE LOOKED LIKE A SUPERSTAR.
Janice: I SEE A BEAUTIFUL
WOMAN IN EVA.
I SEE, YES,
SHE'S GROWN INCREDIBLY.
BUT I'M MORE PRONE
TO YAYA'S REFINEMENT.
I WATCH BOTH OF THE GIRLS
PAINSTAKINGLY
IN THE FASHION SHOW, AND YAYA
IS THE MORE VERSATILE MODEL.
Nolé: EVA NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
WHO SHE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
AS A MODEL.
Nigel: I FIND HER AMUSING.
SHE MAKES ME SMILE
WHEN SHE'S IN FRONT OF ME.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN REALLY LEARN THAT EASILY.
YOU EITHER HAVE THAT
OR YOU DON'T.
Janice: WELL,
THEY BOTH HAVE IT.
Nigel: THEY BOTH HAVE IT, BUT--
Janice: THEY BOTH HAVE IT.
THEY'RE JUST DIFFERENT
IN WHAT YOU PREFER.
Tyra: YAYA--HER BODY
IS CRAZY, AMAZING.
BODIES LIKE THIS
DON'T COME AROUND OFTEN.
Nolé: BUT EVA--
SHE'S LIKE A CINDERELLA.
SHE COMES IN LIKE A LITTLE
TOUGH BOY, AND SHE TURNED
INTO THIS INCREDIBLY GORGEOUS,
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN.
Nigel: I'M VERY TORN,
BECAUSE I HAVE INSTINCTS
WHICH SAY YAYA,
BUT THEN I HAVE ANOTHER SIDE
OF ME WHICH SAYS EVA.
Tyra: THIS IS HORRIBLE.
Tyra: IN A MOMENT,
I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU GUYS HAVE HAD
QUITE A JOURNEY.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING RIGHT NOW?
Yaya: TRYING TO STAY
ON MY FEET.
I FEEL LIKE COLLAPSING.
Eva: I'LL CRY BECAUSE,
REGARDLESS IF I WIN OR LOSE,
THIS FEELING
IS SO OVERWHELMING.
IT'S...
I'M SPEECHLESS.
Tyra: THIS DECISION
WAS VERY HARD TO MAKE.
IT WAS SO HARD BECAUSE YOU TWO
ARE SO DIFFERENT.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE STRENGTHS
AND WEAKNESSES.
BOTH OF YOU REPRESENT BEAUTY
FROM TWO DIFFERENT ASPECTS.
YAYA, YOU WENT FROM THE GIRL
THAT THE JUDGES WERE LIKE,
"HMM, GREAT PICTURES, BUT--"
TO SOMEONE THAT WAS LIKABLE,
SOMEONE THAT WAS RELATABLE,
SOMEONE THAT FINALLY
CAME IN THE ROOM AND SMILED,
SOMEONE THAT KICKED THAT CHIP
UP OFF OF HER SHOULDER.
BUT WE TALKED ABOUT THAT.
AND NOW YOU STAND BEFORE ME
RADIANT AND A TRUE MODEL.
Yaya: THANK YOU.
Tyra: FROM THE INSIDE OUT.
EVA, WHEN YOU WALKED
INTO THE ROOM
AUDITIONING IN LOS ANGELES,
I SAW A PRETTY GIRL
BUT A GIRL THAT WAS LIKE,
"I'M GONNA HATE ON YOU
BEFORE YOU CAN HATE ON ME."
BUT WE HAD OUR TALKS,
AND NOW A REAL MODEL
STANDS BEFORE ME.
BUT I HAVE
TO ANNOUNCE A WINNER.
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE.
Tyra: AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL IS...
Tyra: EVA.
Eva: (screams)
(sobbing)
THIS IS SO UNREAL.
AH!
OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: LET IT OUT, EVA!
Eva: OH, MY GOD,
I'M BEAUTIFUL, A MODEL, ME?
Janice: YOU ARE A MODEL.
Yaya: YOU KNOW,
IN COMPARISON TO OTHER PEOPLE
IN THIS COMPETITION,
I DEFINITELY FELT LIKE
I DESERVED TO BE RECOGNIZED,
AND I WILL.
BUT THEY WANTED SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT MORE BUBBLY,
AND THEY FOUND IT.
Eva: AAH!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OH, MY GOD!
I AM A COVER GIRL.
(gasps)
THIS LITTLE TOMBOY FROM L.A.
THAT HAS NEVER BEEN BEAUTIFUL.
I WAS NOT THE CUTE GIRL
IN SCHOOL.
I CAME IN HERE THE SHORTEST,
THE ONE THAT HAD THE MOST
INSECURITIES INSIDE OF THEM.
NOW I'M
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND I GET TO REPRESENT
ALL THOSE LITTLE GIRLS
THAT FEEL THE WAY I FEEL.
Tyra: EVA HAS VITALITY.
SHE HAS SASS AND SPUNK
THAT MAKE HER RELATABLE
TO YOUNG GIRLS EVERYWHERE.
EVA IS A TRUE COVER GIRL.
Eva: TYRA BANKS JUST TOLD ME
THAT I'M ABOUT TO BE A STAR.
Eva: WATCH OUT, WORLD,
HERE COMES EVA. HA!
Tyra: YOU THINK YOU GOT
WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
GO TO upn.com TO APPLY.